depuis un an la crise sanitaire a
bouleversé le domaine de la culture le
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines est
fermé depuis le 1er novembre pour le
public mais la vie continue à
l'extérieur du théâtre des artistes mène
des ateliers dans les écoles mais aussi
en milieu hospitalier
c'était 15 jours de présence d'une
équipe artistique de la chorégraphe
béatrice massa à l'hôpital pédiatrique
de bullion ou la s adresse aussi bien
aux personnels enfin d'abord aux
patients aux jeunes patients qu'il ya
cent selon dix jeunes patients entre
deux et dix huit ans mais aussi des
personnels encadrants début avril la
tournée du spectacle au nom du père
d'ahmed madani sera représenté 18 fois
dans des collèges et lycées de
rambouillet poissy ou encore guyancourt
à l'intérieur du théâtre les artistes
continuent eux aussi à travailler cette
semaine le spectacle variété inspiré de
discorama une émission télé des années
60 devait être joué il sera finalement
film est plutôt que de faire une
captation classique d'en faire un film
en un film de théâtre donc on va filmer
la pièce mais aussi d'autres choses un
peu autour de la pièce et on va faire un
genre de film de cette pièce voilà parce
que je trouvais important que ce soit
aussi une création que ce soit pas
seulement filmer la pièce telle qu'elle
est mais que nous on se remette au
travail et qu'on puisse inventer des
choses nouvelles
deux nouvelles adaptations aussi pour
les théâtres qui doivent trouver des
solutions comme les live où les
captations pour pouvoir garder un lien
avec les spectateurs
cette période là nous aura appris aussi
être extrêmement réactif et à travailler
sûr sûr sûr sûr ces captations l'a
peut-être une dimension qui manquait au
théâtre mais qui ne peut être qu'une
dimension complémentaire
cette rencontre réelle entre entre le
public et les artistes
contrairement au public les
programmateurs et professionnels de la
profession peuvent toujours assister aux
représentations en physique l'été
culturel 2021 sera l'occasion de
préparer des retrouvailles avec le
public
hors les murs du théâtre